let me let me show you how dark this
evil uh goes man i'm i've got no problem
calling evil i know that each and every
one of you who watch this show will be
shocked
but not surprised
the washington post published an opinion
piece which reads
canada must confront the toxic freedom
convoy head on
you heard that right
the washington post has published an
opinion piece in opposition to
working-class individuals standing up
against the elites because democracy
dies in darkness
let me show you this tweet
this is a tweet from a political
cartoonist i believe from the washington
post michael de atter and it is a
cartoon of truckers with fascism written
on the sides of them i responded these
people think that when the working class
resists the elites it's fascism amen
that they do and they write this article
saying the convoy is by and large a
fringe group an unfortunate minority in
which the further minority of insidious
extremists lurk bolstered by
conservative politicians time and time
again we learn the lesson or at least
come across it that teaches us that
rage-soaked anti-government types can't
be reasoned with this time around the
convoys produce an incoherent memorandum
of understanding premised upon a
misunderstanding of government and
absurd demands of course the memo should
be ignored it's the product of a temper
tantrum but doing nothing is a risky
sub-optimal strategy that's right the
working class of the problem i guess
this ridiculous article wasn't a temper
tantrum but these working-class people
trying to stand for their jobs was also
i love how he called them fascist and
then called them anti-government i don't
know that was different okay the fascist
was the cartoon oh that's right you're
right i'm sorry i shouldn't confuse
those right i love that cartoon and part
of why is because so as a political
cartoonist you know sometimes you swing
and miss but i can't imagine doing a
cartoon where you like literally just
drew a picture and then wrote bad on it
that's what he did he sure did i'm going
to draw trucks and write fascism
ben garrison yeah he even signed it like
ben garrison
he's just but ben garrison does label
everything
but at least they're still funny so i'd
so i i
checked the author david moscop wrote
that op-ed and um so about the author
david boskop is a political theorist
with an interest in democrat democratic
deliberation
what does that mean well i guess he
wants us to have democracy where we are
deliberative in our and are coming to
conclusions unless of course that
deliberate relation leads to conclusions
that are adverse to david moss cops at
which point it becomes fascism right to
me the irony is rich his his book is too
dumb for democracy so clearly he's
smarter than everybody else too
those daggone truckers are messing
everything up his book is called too
dumb for democracy it is well it's an
admission
that his autobiography next week
next week's guest on tim cass david
no i don't know about that uh i just
think it's funny this this this article
is like written by a comic book villain
it's a bunch of buzzwords
the people are rising up against us they
want their rights those pathetic
truckers
anti-government types was that one of
the words that they used in here
anti-government types can you imagine
being it's something the government does
it's a type but it's like they're not
even they're not even it's not even the
craziest product i've ever seen it's
like people driving trucks
you know in in the united states when
they burn that when blm burns down
whatever they're like this is democracy
it's like this is people with jobs these
people with jobs like representing their
jobs let's juxtapose this headline on to
say antifa burning a courthouse in
portland we're trying um
these antifa protesters must be
confronted head on would be called an
incitement to violence oh yeah they
fired they fired that uh new york times
editor because he ran the op-ed from tom
cotton sending the troops or whatever
but uh
when you have when you have uh anti-fun
black lives matter engage in violence
what is it aoc like protests are
supposed to make you uncomfortable
like yo they literally killed people
dude i don't know it's a bit beyond
discomfort where does it say it's
supposed to be peaceful like i thought
you've got to die yeah yeah businesses
were burned down people's lives billions
right like
billions of dollars who's leading the
comments and those by the way those
places are are not going to recover for
a very long time i did uh so there's a
second youtube channel i run with the
foundation for economic education if you
guys want to check it out it's called
common sense soapbox and we did a video
on the riots and how much it's cost this
country and the communities it's
happened in in the long run and it's i
mean it's really astounding and i have
to consult the figures again but i
recommend all you this is just what and
what community says it happened in
exactly right
these are these are socio-economically
challenged people who the left says they
champion who are absolutely screwed by
virtue of this violence absolutely and
and the people who are who i mean
the greatest racism visited upon
americans today is is failing schools
that
disproportionately impact what
social economically challenge people and
people of color
right so but meanwhile we're calling
everybody in this room a racist i
actually give a damn i want these young
people to have a freaking chance because
that's what the promise of america is
it's not an outcome it's a chance and
also i did interrupt you and i apologize
oh but
before the show before i just met
sheamus he's like watch i'm going to
interrupt you i did i was it was a ploy
it was it was pre-meditated interruption
but then they high-fived
and then i interrupted him to apologize
good job good work
just just to loop this back into what
you were saying earlier about
republicans who are like but they'll
call us racist
do you i have to imagine there are
democrats who also have the same
mentality of we can't like so a better
example is when you mentioned uh the
obamacare appeal there are democrats who
are like we're going to pass this bill
to help minorities don't actually vote
for it like in that video where aoc uh
is sitting down and the nancy pelosi
walks up to her and wiggles her arms on
c-span you don't know what they say but
then all of a sudden aoc changes their
vote things like that i'm sure they're
happening like no no we have to pretend
like we just narrowly didn't get this
passed so we can earn votes so they give
leave to certain members in certain
districts to vote a certain way because
they think it might be politically
helpful dude i don't want anyone
representing me who won't vote the way
that they told me they were going to
vote when they ran for office
stribalism it's it's just that's what it
is it's
so my dad was a realtor and but his
political theory was like here's a
novelty tell people what you're going to
do and then try to do it
right and it'll work and you know for
i don't know 10 12 years in elected
office it did for me but yeah that's
that's gone right i mean we're hosed so
so tom can i ask you it sounds like
working within the system you saw a lot
of things that were very disillusioning
i'm curious
would you say that you became more
pessimistic about the political system
or did you maybe become more optimistic
about your ability to effect change
outside of it ultimately where would you
say it's placed dude um
so i'm on three committees i'm on
homeland security which is and this is
past tense but which is like the worst
committee there is it sounds super cool
but like they have no power because
everything's a turf war in dc and it's a
new committee so nobody relinquished any
power so we just go talk i'm on foreign
affairs which i fell in love with which
is where they go to warehouse the
pro-liberty people like how much harm
can a legislative branch guide do when
he's in an executive branch arena
foreign affairs and then i'm on
educational workforce and you go to
these committee meetings there's 50
members in the committee and somebody
fact-checked me it's probably 51 or 49 i
don't know but like normally there's
five or six in the room they come they
do their two-minute talk they ask some
questions they leave right because we've
gotten so far beyond the enumerated
powers envisioned by the founders that
nobody can carry the bandwidth and they
know nobody cares which pisses me off
because this stuff matters
and so nobody's ever there micro comes
in from dirty jobs to speak to ed
workforce and he starts by the way when
i grow up i don't know if i want to be
tim pool or micro yeah one of them mike
rowe is pretty rad he's pretty great but
so mike rose starts off by saying mike
rowe and i'm a trained professional
opera singer and i know nothing about it
in workforce but i care passionately
about it right that's how he starts
but every single but every single butt
is in seat every democrats in the room
every republicans in the room and
they're all scrawling down what mike
rowe who starts his comments by saying
that i'm not an expert but i care about
this they're writing stuff down and i'm
and so that's when i thought like the
aristotle quote like you give me the
storytellers i give you the future and
i'm hating washington from the second
day i'm there i'm like this place is
broken beyond my ability to fix it and
the coolest thing i've ever done is like
literally snatch people out of prison
against the will of the president and
the committee chair and everybody
because i wanted to do something
freaking mattered and i thought son of a
[ __ ] i can do more good telling stories
that aren't being told that i can ever
do in office that was the light bulb
moment and it wasn't like oh and exile
series was born like i didn't know how
to make point a reach point b
but i knew that micro was more powerful
than nancy pelosi at that moment i could
not tim poole was more power no [ __ ]
right i'm not just kissing your butt um
like
because
if you're loud enough and you scream
long enough washington will do something
but you have to tell the story but let
me tell you
cultural enforcement is more powerful
than law
so the way i explain it is that we have
a bunch of laws on the books that no one
ever enforces laws you can there's books
called like silly laws you know and
there's one where it's like you can't
put a pie on the windowsill on sundays
and it was passed in you know 17 90
because some guy put a pie on the
windowsill attracted bears and then they
were like guys you got to stop putting
pies in the window so we're going to
write this down and not still on the
books right so we have these silly laws
but no cop is going to walk up to you
because you had a pie in the windowsill
and care about it at all but hold on
that law is on the books does the cop
just get to decide i won't enforce that
law the cop doesn't even know the law
exists
so if the culture changes it doesn't
matter what a politician says
yeah right why do people not beat their
wives hopefully
because you don't beat your wife because
it's a jackass horrible thing to do yeah
it's been illegal but that's why people
don't do it so you're exactly right but
we had a conversation a while back too
about cops choosing i think we had a cop
we had some you know former cops on the
show saying like well cops can't choose
what laws to enforce them like they
literally do every single day otherwise
they'd be arrested some dude for having
a shower on a tuesday in in
massachusetts or whatever because these
laws are on the books but just as
important now there are sort of benign
the pie on the window sill on sunday
laws that are still in the books but
then there are laws that are still in
the books
that are never going to be enforced
because they're horrible and the
politicians still lack the courage to
repeal them my favorite that i had
anything to do with was virginia had up
until 2016 a crimes against nature along
the books which made it illegal for
anyone to have any sex other than
missionary between a man and his wife it
was a freaking felony
it was a felony
to have any sex other than the
missionary between a man and his wife
and it was on the books it was a felony
and so in in 2005 cops enforcing it and
and two but well they still so
story in 2005 a democrat named patsy
tyser from northern virginia carried a
bill to repeal it and it failed
and i'm like i'm the like i got a
evangelical biblical sort of
constituency but i'm looking at this
going this is horrible
so i write the repeal bill but i carved
out to leave it illegal if it was an
adult and a minor right because you know
and then the headline was garrett's
obsessed with teenage sex and i'm like
only when it's my teenager and you're 40
year old then you know we're locking
your butt up for that but we we took
that off the books because here's the
thing as a former prosecutor every law
that's on the books that's selectively
enforced or not enforced
waters down the meaning of every law
that's on the books that is enforced
because i as a rational thinking person
will go
why do i obey that while they don't
enforce exactly or they don't enforce
that one uniformly
but back to your point about you know
this show or any other show people need
to realize if to if tomorrow every
single person woke up and just said uh
the us dollar is no longer the currency
i care about bitcoin is then bitcoin is
currency and the dollar is worth nothing
so long as the system has confidence in
it so these are these are really
important points for people to
understand the philosophy of how our
society works
when when republicans are like we're
going to get a bunch of judges appointed
i'm like wow that's completely
meaningless
because when they come out and they get
a supreme court ruling the federal
judges won't really matter when they
come out and everyone on tv says you're
racist and then gop members are like we
can't pass that bill they'll call us
racist the cultural enforcement is
substantially stronger than any
statutory law yeah i remember having a
conversation with you a while ago i
think it was around the time we first
met but you made a good point that as
long as you change the language you
don't actually have to change law so i
think this was off the heels of the
civil rights laws being interpreted as
saying you had to um cater to certain
delusions with respect to transgenderism
which is certainly not what was intended
back in the 1960s
but because our cultural understanding
shifted it was argued that this law was
actually uh meant to be enforced in a
very specific way uh well so just sorry
to interrupt but the specific point
you're everything just so people and
then i'll throw it back but is uh if the
1964 civil rights act says you know you
can't discriminate against the basis of
sex or whatever or they say you know
women have the right to x y and z equal
to men
if those laws in the books use the word
woman but then later on you have a major
cultural push to change the definition
of the word woman the law changes after
the fact exactly and i agree with so
this this wonderful aristotle quote
about storytelling
i wholeheartedly agree with that i
i think it's so important for people to
recognize that the best avenue for for
political and cultural change isn't just
political i mean that's part of it you
do want something there but it's really
shaping hearts and minds and this is a
huge part why a huge reason why i think
it's good to just stay away from
hollywood entertainment generally even
if there's not anything in it that you
think is particularly morally
objectionable a lot of these stories are
written by people who hate you and hate
your family and hate your way of life
and want to reshape the country and the
idea that the kinds of stories that they
tell aren't at all going to have their
worldview bleed into it and influence
you on some level is just ridiculous in
my opinion when you say they hate you
you mean the more that they your way of
life they they work counter to your your
belief and like what like because they
don't know you you're so they don't know
use an individual person but also the
idea well so let's say you have
a christian or a trump supporter or a
conservative who's listening to this
right now there are many screenwriters
in hollywood who would say i do hate
that type of person well that you said
they don't know you but they think they
know exactly exactly well that's exactly
uh going back to your reference uh of
this show and we can you know mention
many other shows be it you know ben
shapiro stephen crowder uh the pro-life
movement is a really good example there
was this really funny thing that
happened we were talking about where
this democratic congressman said if
pro-lifers or if republicans think that
life begins a conception then i'm going
to pass a bill that makes men
financially responsible for babies
starting a conception based
and they posted it in this like leftist
they posted it in this you know like
leftist subreddit and they were like ha
ha that'll show these conservatives and
then all the conservatives were sharing
going like this is awesome exactly
that's how i felt i was like this is
fantastic yeah i love that good make men
responsible for their children why would
why would a conservative who cares about
the family not want men to be
responsible for their children but this
is the point
they think they know you exactly based
on media manipulation from people like
people like rachel maddow who lie who
make things up and not just people like
rachel maddow i think more importantly
the people who make films and television
shows who work conservative characters
into them who act so so the bill so the
sodomy bill rep repeal and i've over
characterized it i think it was less
broad than anything other than the
missionary between a men and women but a
friend of mine named adam evan who was
the first openly gay man in the virginia
senate he's a democrat i go to adam and
i'm like i'm gonna do the sodomy bill
repeal i want you to co-patron it with
me he's like i can't it's your bill like
we're friends
he's like
and again i went through the whole this
is homophobic and i'm like son of a
[ __ ] i'm like trying to like i mean
like i'm the last guy who cares what
anybody does in their bedroom right like
that's between whomever you're doing it
with in god so long as they're of age
and with consent so yeah man i mean
we're going to paint this however when a
gay rva is a publication out of richmond
virginia and and one of the guys comes
to me and goes what you're trying to do
is this and i'm like yeah he's oh dude
i'm on your team i'm like hello
it's really commendable
you actually made a bill to repeal
another law like i think these laws
should have sunset clauses built in so
you don't have to go through all the
effort it's just like
virginia right we had a bill in the
books that says that you can't marry
somebody of a different race wth right i
mean like two human beings who are in
love right so what do i want for my kids
i want them to be happy now i'm i'm a
person whose life has been changed by
god's grace that's my belief instruction
belief structure but what i really want
because happiness is like more valuable
than gold dude it's it's so rare there's
there's a
probably an urban legend but they say
that uh is a reddit post it was like
when john lennon was a kid his teacher
said what do you want to be when he when
you grow up and he wrote down in his
assignment happy and the teacher said
you've misunderstood the assignment and
he said you've misunderstood life
i don't think he really did that no i
don't think i think i don't think john
lennon is that interesting i don't think
he would say something like that as a
child i think he might have actually it
is john lennon
hey he's made an interesting point that
cultural enforcement overweighs law and
i think that's because law is a type of
cultural enforcement it's just a
specific one but it's downstream yeah it
is it's like a little bit of it the
grand cultural enforcement is media you
see that so people defining language
people say that like law and politics or
downstream of culture and there's truth
in that but i think it's much more
cyclical because the laws that we have
do influence the way people think so you
you were mentioning this earlier about
how
certain outdated laws on the books that
are that are no longer enforced or laws
that people don't care about actually
shape a person's understanding of other
laws and i think on some level we could
argue that that's cultural the law is a
teacher thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you